we are the crystal gems with Steven and
Steven and Steven and Steven and I was
it at Steven though it was just before
they like you know they counted up to
like 40 something so and Steven and
Steven Holvey long have fun and Steven
oh um this is Steven and the Stevens I
just is as the multiplicity episode
that's your first thing I thought it was
oh my god it's like multiplicity this
ideas been done a lot where it's like
someone keeps trying to go back in time
right saying it's it's right ripoff
multiple is I'm just saying they should
be I will say fit design this is the
first time I've seen this concert where
someone keeps going back in time and
whatever arguing themselves and they
don't get on something but they want to
start a rock band I just love that the
first thing keep is stupid selfish
reason yeah Mike and Tom well especially
like especially when the obvious answer
is Steve the ending there as I said boy
isn't that kind of very obviously I was
with you I'm like that was beams that
would have been my first thoughts like
although Jesse second ask I could ask
the three women around me with
impeccable singing voices and
superpowers or I could travel back in
time again and again to grab multiple
versions of myself to create this band
from scripted constants this is what you
doing but uh it was still fun to me
again for an idea I think we've seen a
lot of times it's kind of fun to see
Stephen go through that and so it
reminded me logic you'll hear that it
was like multiplicity across with that
Red Dwarf episode where Rimmer gets
another version of himself
I'm the to fight with each other it
turns out Rimmer's his own worse a red
versus blue
where church keeps going back and time
yeah that is like it's not a lot but
it's it's always 40 because it's such an
insight into how funny a character can
be when there's just so many of them and
especially when they don't get along
what a great metaphor for naruse yeah
yeah killing and about in Stephen
Stephen Stephen divided against himself
cannot stand
even though timeline wise I just don't
think any of this would make sense at
all but well if it's multiple universe
theory could totally make sense I just
you're interested great never bought
multiple time is linear I just never
ever bought the multiple universe then
how did you get through BioShock
Infinite oh it's okay no no it's fun to
kind of speculate stuff but it's like I
in terms of like if time travel could
actually happen I'm just like that's all
those people like I go nuts it's like
they time travel and it's like they're
in the exact same spot it's like no the
earth should be like thousands of miles
over there and rotated I like but I'm
really really weird about that
oh but no but for fiction sake that this
is fun and funny um you were Wow it just
always drives me nuts god that was so
cool that work if it's gonna really be
talked about let's talk about we could
really kind of do it but it almost never
is but I know it's like it can't be done
in sci-fi and everything but I'm like
think so what if it was I think Steven
universe isn't the only metaphor for
neurosis I know I know it's a stupid
thing that says over but uh but no it's
still a fun episode um I think there is
no worst enemy than yourself that's a
great more yes the self hate in this is
quite apparent you know this is a weird
thing to comment on but in the opening
after they get back from their you know
their little quests and stuff and he's
gonna head out to Picchu Palooza he just
opens the door there's a little crab
there it just is after you sir and the
crab leaves you could have cut that
there is no reason to animate that but
it's just a nice little touch that just
adds to the likability Doug they carry
the crabs everywhere yeah I speak for
you ah ah and a blue crab see um but no
just those little touches I think really
do add a lot and yeah it's still it's
like I said oh yeah I guess guys its
semi predictable and what's gonna happen
but in terms of starting the band I'm
just like a fair enough I've never seen
that before I just never seen all them
come together and like do a great big
band so I like that angle um that hurt
that hurt the blue crab mm-hmm well
stopping a dick which case in point
Lars is back with the good Chi I knew
you're gonna do then
I don't like it nothing has changed
fucking nothing it's like we thought
we'd have to wait episodes to talk about
this again but nope nothing you know
what maybe on a very special episode of
Steven universe there will be a domestic
violence call maybe the larvas Sanyo no
you don't be amazingly Joanie shaving
him up there we go Richard Eddie's
arrest yeah
then I'd just be like holy shit what is
going on I I am so with wherever this is
going now guess I can't predict them at
all okay I must admit some
disappointment yes I knew you were gonna
bring that up the second I saw I liked
it quite a lot generally to be long now
save it for the V like um you sprang it
on me like a surprises but but outside
of that uh episodes fine it's fun a one
reaction I really like it's just a
totally different reaction by that was
really funny is when the waters breaking
through in the opening and there Steve
and he goes back gets a little Thai
thing running in just that mountain
water comes in she took just thought
what a genuinely original Rio's now such
as suddenly I'm that was a great
literally hysterical break yeah it was
like can't tell if I should laugh cry or
scream oh yeah
she chose to do all three yeah I was I
was good I like that
yeah I thought it was very very funny um
but uh yeah no uh it's still a lot of
fun I you know I always said I liked um
I got it the most but amethyst I got
admit just for the pure going with
anything and not carrying it just
causing chaos like she's gonna be more
and more just like when she's there's
the drummer she just didn't care so
who'd you get a drummer it's like you
know amethyst it's like yeah I'm not for
anything and it's like that's a good
like she won't be like yeah you can stop
in orientation so yeah whatever that's
the thing not only does she not care
about the fact that there's now 30
Stevens floating around trying to create
a band or whatever I think she would
have encouraged Danny I'm sure would
have been like yeah you know what good
do it see how many other Stevens you can
bring back it'll be fun we'll party yeah
I mean I've never disliked or anything I
liked her fine but it's like I'm liking
her more and more as like whatever Oh
Pearl's fine needy pearl she's a good
character that laughs amazing you know
if they can play up more than to rob go
run you just pull the Leonardo from
Turtles of wheels fine yeah you need bit
character you need a leader but no no no
if they do more of that neurotic site
with the Laughing like that
then I like her more uh yeah but she's
no she's a good girl like a more but
girls represent I try think there's any
that I don't know I just even from the
first episode I just didn't like Lars as
a character I think he's boring at these
of Jerky's unlikable and then we when
it's an episode like hey Lars is gonna
be the big focus I'm like shit do you
reminds me of their bully onna off of
Doug yeah it's kind of like that it was
same kind of voice when I'm thinking
about yeah just kind of a boring bully
and I know they try to give him a little
bit more depth and stuff but then they
do like that incredible dick thing in
the last episode it just makes me bit
more likeable I mean I'm indifferent to
him so but oh we brought up Doug so did
it do Dee do Dee do Dee do you angry
girl god
I like it what's on that you guys it's
lost its true no no what I really like
is when someone tries to say like if
someone's mad at me or something tries
to send an email or some on Facebook
like you know hey look what I found
haha take that it's like yes I really
get so angry at that guy this is what
really gets under my blood I think some
fans think they're literally rickrolling
you and they do them yeah and they and
they think it's like no don't like I
said people it's like you know and say
like you know I hate your view on
whatever man this nostalgic or this even
adventure time or something like that so
here you go and like they'll just put
that in there it's like it is this
really supposed to make it's really
hilarious really hilarious when they
type it out I'm like that's not gonna
make Doug angry just makes you look like
a crazy person
oh but uh it would have been much more
it would have been much more impressive
if they posted the sheet music that at
least I give boys our key I do an
outburst just for like you know
someone's gonna do it now you know
they're gonna turn out well yeah my
facebook somebody's gonna post it but um
and then don't be like 80 of them it's
like shit I got doing outrage on all
these or something do something funny
dozen kids puppet dudes
um but uh yeah boy we got tracking and
sorry uh but no you talk about
everything yeah
no there's a good episode and very funny
and uh yeah we'll just see you at
episode um confirm are you sure you want
to quit playback see that ok or cancel
ok